[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
and the crazy part in this business when
it's downhill brother it is straight
down straight down it's directly
straight down i mean we can ask we know
a lot of people that have already
plummeted that far you know
bert's not putting his shirt off anymore
he's keeping his shirt on well they had
charged some lady filed a charge against
him she did yeah what was it what you
know what just like indecency or
something just from complete indecency
too much indecency dude i remember when
i was young the first fella i even ever
masturbated to was a buddy who had big
tits like that
[Laughter]
how big were they this boy i don't want
to say his name man because he's a nice
boy oh is he he's still alive yeah yeah
he's still alive i remember telling some
girl like i remember being stuck in this
bedroom like laying on my back on this
bed or couch and i was so high like
everybody else had gotten high and going
to do something fun right right and i
was like all right i'm coming and as i'm
getting up to leave out of the door
i can't i couldn't get out of my body i
couldn't my body was stuck in there yeah
and so i'm like laying there and some
girl came back in the room to get
something right and i remember just
being like hey hey hey you know
get me you know get me
and i remember this girl [ __ ] looking
at me and i think she thought i was
trying to hit on her or something i
might have been you know because even
half and half yeah
even though i'm down for the count you
know i can't move but i'll [ __ ] yeah
halfway through a 10 count i'll still
get my dick up you know even at six i'll
[ __ ] say come [ __ ] you know but um
but i remember this girl just looking at
me and i remember speaking but i
couldn't i it was the only scent like
skill i had left was to speak to get it
out yeah like
get me get me you know and they left man
and i remember being trapped there
literally felt like i was loitering in
my own body that wouldn't move yeah like
just wandering around always in my body
get out of my body
i had i i got so high one time at a
college party
and i went in this girl's room
uh to just get away from people because
i was getting i was like my heart was
jumping i was feeling really [ __ ] up
and i was like having a panic attack
that i'm like i'm too drunk i'm too
[ __ ] high i'm on a few things i'm
feeling real [ __ ] up so i go i go oh
dude i hate it i go and sit down in her
bed and i curled up and i woke up to her
and her roommate screaming at me like
get the [ __ ] out get the [ __ ] out you
[ __ ] pieces
i was like not too lazy i knew
something's too high i had like to drive
tears at this point because i cried
prayed to god ten times don't don't
don't let me die like this in this
[ __ ] this girl's one bedroom one bath
i don't i just don't want to die in a
small place yeah i want to die in a big
house it doesn't have to be mine yeah
but if i'm going to die of drugs i want
to die in a big house oh wow you know
dining in a small place is sad yeah if
you're right there they find you right
away they walk in they know you're right
there there's no there's no
investigation there's no mystery there's
no allure right there's no hearing their
heels uh walk on the on the nice floors
as they look for you yeah no where could
he be is he in here no
no no not in there
upstairs yeah
yeah
and he's not up here
we have the
probably one of the top 60 or 70 gingers
in america right now
top top 30 or 40 yeah according to
jingerunite.com and you know that when
there's a biopic or biopic you're going
to play
louis c.k in it
actually i'm hoping to be ron howard
when he dies yeah i'll be running
handsome uh first of all first of all
bro i'm way more handsome than ron
howard
who would you play in a biopic who would
you play huh who would you play in a bio
in a biopic i would when they die who
will you play
maybe
um
let me think about that for a second one
of the clampetts
no you yeah one of the clampets maybe
that's so limiting okay well then maybe
you could play uh at least louie is a
role you can do something he's something
real yeah you would play um
you could do brad pitt
no i'm not gonna do it not looks wise
just confidence wise
no i definitely don't have that
confidence so you know the rapid
confidence no i think i could do
jeff
garland you could do jeff garland oh no
he can't even turn his neck
um let me do oh big lebowski
the dude yeah you talking about the
actor yeah jeff bridges
yeah you could be jeff bridges you think
let's hear it all right uh
market eight
donny
no let me try it again
uh
i don't know what they're talking about
do you not know any lines from the movie
huh yeah it sounds like you don't know
any [ __ ] lines from the movie
market donny jeff bridges dude i know
what i'm talking about i've always had a
tough time of knowing like how well i
know people or not you know
like i remember one time i went to
somebody's like babies christening or
something and they're like what in the
[ __ ] are you doing here dude like you
don't even [ __ ] know
and i was like oh [ __ ] man
but i but but you but you were being
nice you're like i just want to see the
baby get burst yeah like i want to see
this the blessing you know well i want
yeah dude look bruh and the baptism dude
i freaking still remember dude
i remember taking a couple extra sips
when i was under that water bro you were
gonna stand down there
i remember the first time i stole one of
those um
the blood of christ at a catholic church
because you did you did you do some
altar bullying no i did none of that
really we weren't catholic really dude
you should do a series about being a
taller alter like a you know the tallest
altar boy yeah the tall boy yeah
the taller boy the talter boy yeah yeah
the talter boy
you totally because let me just say this
anytime people look at you they think
you've done ultra boring do you think
that
i think so yeah i did it so i know my
kind
oh really you were an altar boy yeah
yeah i was safe though i think they knew
i would squeeze is that why you got that
one wandering eye yeah
i'm just learning about this
he has to refocus every couple of
seconds you know you see it recheck a
little bit oh just checking for the yeah
he's good but he's good because he's got
he's got his eyes on a swivel eyes on
the lord looking for the devil he's
always looking for the devil that's why
he's a smart cat no we were we weren't
catholic enough for me to be a part of
the church i also got asked to leave
sunday school
multiple times i could see that though i
just didn't enjoy the content
yeah it just was like i was i was always
i questioned everything that's why i
like jews that's part of their religion
is to question more catholics are like
don't ask
none of your business
jews are like inquire and choir yeah
let's see what's going on let's figure
this out yeah they're they're all there
they're all the time but sometimes the
questions just go too far it's like oh
dude everybody relax yeah let's slow
down let's chill out dude it's just
yogurt you know
you don't need to get the fingerprint
kit out
yeah you seem like somebody that was oh
my god i wake up i go to the bathroom i
go to bed i wake up i go i go write
something down i watch tv
i i can't sleep through the night write
something down yeah what is this are you
in like are you
on a ship and there's also murder
mysteries week to week and if i think of
the blood was on his shoe and then i'll
write it down no if i get a thought that
i can't i need like yeah you got it
right you put it in your phone don't you
put stuff in your phone like that yeah
let me i'll read a couple yeah read
something that you throw down in your
phone recently let me see what what a
comic's condition but of mine's about
gays and a lot of mines are racial stuff
too oh same oh blind puzzle making i
thought would be good if they had a game
show where it was blind people making
puzzles you know oh i love that uh this
says why do adults like to get spanked
why do adults like to get spanked during
sex
it's gross it's indicative of childhood
trauma
it's very strange like knock it out
knock that trump yeah you want to spank
the trauma right out of me yeah that's
where the term daddy bothers me when i
have a son i'll i'll hit him in the face
if he calls me daddy yeah i'm papa or
pop or dad yeah daddy is gross daddy
yuck oh yeah daddy's too much it's gross
father
father father's nice yes father yes boy
yes yeah go fetch your pale yeah go
fetch your pale boy
who do you trust les schaab or or callan
i think
one of them is a patsy and i think it's
you think it shall but it's callan
see my see that's weird because i think
the patsy would be calling my first
instinct when i see him because he's
tiny and little he's kind of like
you know i don't know he's like a little
sneaky i can hide very well little beady
little creepy eyes oh definitely his
eyes sleep color tree yeah he sleeps up
in a tree well here's the thing if you
zoom in on crystallia's dick right
behind it there's two nuts and that's
brendan and brian oh these dudes are
hanging on that [ __ ] guy's dick two
people should be allowed to use it
legally it says the ruling means the
unnamed pair can use but not sell
according to mexico united against crime
huh
they need that energy to get back and
forth and back and forth over that
border you know
yeah it's like playing it's like red
rover
that's a brown rover down there
i said on uh i said on uh
krista stefano's podcast with giannis
papas i said they were joking about
building the wall and i said the wall is
cruel like it's a cruel thing but i
think it'd be funny if it was a maze
yeah like if they had to like really
you know if it was an obstacle course
yeah like if it was american ninja
warrior down there yeah i'd be so down
for that well dude and then the people
that would be coming in you'd be getting
some real heroes
athletes crossing the border well i
think there should be a return system
that's that's what i think it's like
one enters one lease it's like there's i
wish there was a level in america for
people that don't want to try and
contribute it all to society yeah that
we get to tr you know oh that's smart
like it's like a battle royale you have
to prove why you get to stay and someone
has to go yes that's dope that's a great
idea or let vegas bet on people at a
certain point at the border to like
another point let them bet like just on
who is gonna get can they make it to the
next level yeah it's like mario we're
setting up super mario brothers and
seeing what level they pass they have to
beat a boss at every oh every point and
then they they get certain you know you
can get wings you know what i mean you
get a jet pack if you want
you get to jump over people some guy is
flying by like man i'm lost man
going to level three
you ruined two days now yeah i used to
be able to do drugs and function go to
work yeah i should do drugs at work yeah
yeah yeah think about that half the
people that are at work all right or on
drugs yeah all the chefs at a kitchen
bro yeah if your order comes out quick
that's drugs that's drugs yeah people
are like oh man this this restaurant is
great dude he's just he's amped the [ __ ]
up that's drugs he's on meth
eggs hashbrowns eggs
tough eggs you know you're baltimore
just like tough yeah man that's a tough
town to live baltimore is a tough town
to live in dude baltimore's uh the only
show i ever had where they had to stop
the show because people were fighting in
the audiences baltimore
was that for a comedy factory is that
what it was at or no what was that i
don't know it's not the name of that
club i can't remember the name of that
club the power and light district
somebody got shot while i was in
baltimore in that area uh the day that i
got into baltimore somebody got shot and
i was i remember talking to manager and
being like
man that's nuts right and he's like
not really
that's not too uncut he was like it
happens you know i was like i hope it
doesn't happen this weekend he's like no
they got they got one out of the way
they'll be extra security all weekend
who is worse friends oh uh huh so you
your y'all's new show is called bad
friends bad friends yeah and who is
worst friends you and bobby or me and um
what's it called pirates booty himself
bernie shout out albanian burning yeah i
think i think you guys are working
barnyard yeah
barn door schluben is probably uh you
guys are worst friends no no no one's
me and bobby are friends i'll ask you
this how about this
bobby and i
are friends because we get mad at each
other all the time okay like are you and
brendan friends because you you you
bicker a lot do you bicker a lot and it
makes you closer or no
well that's a good question i mean yeah
the reason the show even started was
because we were ripping on each other
yeah right okay so with us
it started because we undeniably have
opposing lifestyles so we would we would
tease each other and get mad at each
other for i oh i hated that he played
video games till four in the morning oh
yeah he thinks he thinks sports are are
for losers yeah we're polar opposites i
like that stuff he likes that stuff and
we make fun of each other for but it
just it works like the way that you and
barnard [ __ ] on each other yeah
it's beautiful because i know half of
it's real and half of it's all love yeah
but it's you know there's a bat there's
a balance to all of it yeah it's that
it's that heartfelt dung really a lot of
it you know
it's like hey here's a turd but man i
you know i put a valentine at the end it
looks nice i wrapped it up guys yeah i
wrapped this piece of [ __ ] for you but i
but you mean a lot to me yeah that's
kind of how it is man dude i get a text
i get a dm from this company that i've
never answered but for the past
seven months they've hit me up and they
say who's your jeweler
who do you use as a jeweler they're a
jewelry company
i don't ever wear jewelry i i don't even
wear a wedding ring i don't like jewelry
i don't like stuff and they hit me up
every other week they erase their dm and
they send it again
who's your jeweler i think i might need
to go get some jewelry you think i'm
trying to take a chain oh i could see
you in a chain i could see you in a
wrist in a wrist chain tennis bracelet
but i want it on my ankle like a girl i
want
like a girl on spring break dude i want
one above each knee
yeah i want a thigh
savage yeah right above your knee
wrapped around that's that's dope would
that be funny if you had 20 000 on each
leg i would love that my knees are
blinged out
[Music]
[Music]
ain't no right way just the wrong way
[Music]